each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it's my pleasure to introduce Christian
tapas Christian is here from the
University are from Caltech and talking
to us about speculative execution he's
of course interviewing with the OS group
I he has so Christian I asked Christian
what his hobbies aren't Stefan he has a
five week old son and a son that's
almost two years old so his children are
his outside interest anyway thank you
very much for your kind introduction so
my talk today will be about the super
speculative execution which is
programming models I introduced as part
of my PhD research before I go into the
details of this work I'd like to give a
little motivation behind it and the
first thing that I'd like to mention is
that I believe software reliability is
important but not only because a
software bug would make some home users
unhappy for not being able to watch
their favorite movie or for losing their
mp3 music collection as software leeuwin
devices have become ubiquitous this
issue of software reliability is
becoming an issue for other domains like
car manufacturing and you know think
about five years ago if your car engine
and was stalling you'd say oh you know
yet another mechanical problem I have to
take this to a to the mechanic to fix it
well not anymore
these days we can blame this kind of
problems on software and what comes to
mind is the at heard a prius example
from a couple years ago when a software
glitch in the computer on the tariff yes
was causing the vehicles to stall at
certain high speed high highway speeds
and this was causing you know some
safety issues for the for the
Coronas and it's not that we don't care
about software reliability but I believe
software reliability is hard to miss
difficult to achieve I'm going to show
you here briefly just you know a couple
of images that show some errors that you
don't necessarily want to see you know
you walk into them through a mole you
don't want to have all the walls you
know paper ended with the error messages
we can also see another error here both
the bank and the customers are losing
money but what what's really the point
I'm trying to make here is that the
other problem that we have to think
about is think about reliability and
software reliability beyond the single
device and the single program here this
ATM machine is actually part of a bigger
network so maybe the problem that caused
this was not necessarily a fault on the
local program but maybe because
something on a remote machine failed
caused this to fail so we need to focus
not only on single devices but also take
a you know push this a step further and
look at distributive systems and this is
a picture that I took in Rome a couple
years ago actually few years ago and I
have to tell you that before I took this
picture I was sure that nothing wrong
could happen in critical places like you
know airports and planes you know as far
as software goes
but when you see this it makes you think
and you it makes you wonder you know
maybe we don't know how to make it to
write software for the kind of
distributed environments that we're
seeing these days you know so hopefully
we won't get to a stage where you know
some really really critical piece of
code that's running one of the you know
a plane or something crashes because we
didn't understand the system and the
interaction between these components
yes
so what can we do you know and by we're
here I mean a generic research community
the industry and so on as you know you
know the problem with software
reliability is not because necessarily
we have bad programmers it's also the
fact that software reliability is
expensive and what we need to do as
researcher I think we need to build new
programming models that would make
writing reliable software simpler easier
cheaper so that everybody can afford to
write these kinds of distributed
software we also need to come up with
models that would allow programmers to
think about you know fault tolerance
better and that would allow them to
specify scalable or large-scale system
in a in an easier fashion but also
something that you know may not many
people really do understand these days
especially in the academia is that we
really need to focus on creating models
that would make programmers think about
the computation that they want to build
rather than you know memory allocation
in the allocation or you know how do you
write a recovery code and so on so we
need to separate these two the the
computation from the error recovery code
and just make that transparent to the
user and the programmer the other thing
we I think we should look at is how can
we specify these largely severe systems
what does it mean to specify a component
if I have two programs that I know
they're correct what happens if I run
them in a shared environment would they
still perform to the specifications that
they have with their correctness be
affected by this composability and we
need to come up with ways of reasoning
about these systems that you know we can
then pour through to building
programming models last but not least I
think we need also need to come
with tools that will allow us to debug
these discrete applications you know
there might not be necessarily typo bugs
the type of type like bytes that we have
in our code there could be some
conceptually wrong things with the code
so we need to have the tools that can
handle the types of system that we're
building these days well enough for the
preaching and right now I'm going to
describe you briefly some of the
projects that I've been working on as a
graduate student and really great thing
about Cal Tech is that they really don't
force their students to take on one
particular project and go with that all
the way to the end of their PhD the gift
the garrisons freedom to get involved in
other projects you know work with people
in even other departments and this is
what I actually did for my first year I
was collaborating with people in the
control systems and current dynamic
systems department and they had this
wonderful wireless testbed for multi
vehicles where they were checking
dynamics on them and so on but the
problem that they had there is they had
these cooperating robots using a static
configuration file for who should take
control of the group if one know if one
particular robot fails and there was not
no good reason for that they simply just
didn't know how to to do this right
because they were really concerned with
another problem so I came in and said
well what if I come up with a dynamic
leader election algorithm that would be
suited for this kind of you know
wireless environment that you're working
on something that would be full tore
into a certain extent and they will
allow you to dynamically configure who
takes control of business and metrics
that matter to you so I did this and
they were very happy make their system
more versatile and more robust and this
project was actually the origin of
another challenge the vendor to build a
full torrent group communication library
as I was
this leader election protocol I realized
that I need means to communicate between
processes that you know small groups of
processes in a reliable manner and that
I needed to have ways to specify the
membership of these groups and so on
while preserving certain invariants and
reason about you know the correctness of
this protocol so I went ahead and now
this project actually has a life of
itself we have a new graduate student
than an hour graduate working on this
and they're trying to push this forever
I also worked on a another project which
where we're trying to build a trusted
compiler so I joined a group of people
from the compilers group and what we
tried to do there we try to reduce the
amount of trusted code in the compiler
to a small set of rewritable x' these
rules were written in a textbook like
manner in other transformations of a
program and then we used a we guide
engine of a theory improver which was
called medical developed criminal to
apply these rules these transformations
to take the program all the way from
source to assembly language
well-trusted meaning trusted rather than
necessarily proven correct because the
proofs that we're doing were by
inspection of the rules of the rules we
we looked at them we made sure that the
rules were correct the transformation
that we described were correct and we
knew that the rewrite engine was
applying the transformation correctly so
the rewrite engine of the theorem Hoover
was proven to be correct so that that if
you specify the certain transformation
that the transformation itself would be
applied correctly so what we had to do
we inspected the rules make sure that
those were correct and also the glue
code that was specifying the order in
which you wanted to apply them wasn't
really proven was proven by inspection
if you want by saying this rules but it
was more of an exercise to see whether
we can do some things with the theorem
prover is used just to apply this
transformation rules these rules so the
transformation rules that describe how a
program held the state of a program
transform from one state to another if
you want but the main reason we actually
use the theorem prover was because we
trusted the rewrite engine and we didn't
have to do any internal allocation for
you know state and all this was all done
through simple transformation of the
code we compiled a subset of Okemo
functional language so and the way we we
worked actually we and we had this was
the you know the core of the of the
system and then we say this was the core
of the system we only had recursive
functions and then we added new features
to the the language like arrays integer
summary Atlantic and boolean operators
and this were just the extension so the
correctness the other thing the other
interesting part
think about this compiler was that you
know we had a set of rules here that
describe just how functions were
transformed and then whenever somebody
wanted to add a feature they came up
with a set of new rules like new nine
new goals for type inference of race
another 17 rules for the type checking
of a race and so on but these new goals
that we were creating did not affect the
correctness of the existing rules so
this were independent so the the nice
feature of this compiler was its
modularity as well whereas in a typical
compiler and this is was actually the
reason we started this we had this
compiler that was we're trying to
compile ML code and C code and to a
common intermediate representation but
the idea was that it got up to a point
where we had I think about 300 thousand
lines of code and there were like five
six people working on this and every
time a new person joined the group for
adding a new feature they would you know
with a probability of 90% break
something else in the system because
they had to interact with other
components we said well is there a
better way of doing this a problem that
with this approach was that using this
theory improver and well and the
description of the rules we couldn't
really do any entire the analysis of the
entire programs we were only looking at
local transformations of the program so
we can really implement many of the
optimizations and so on so but we just
wanted to see whether we can do
something different and finally the core
of my research there at Caltech was
coming up with this new programming
model based on distributed speculations
speculative executions in the context of
distributed computing
so the rest of in my talk is organized
as follows first I'll talk about why do
we need a new programming model you know
is this necessarily the solution I
believe it is and you know I'll give you
an example of how I think this
programming all that I introduced will
make things better also and I will
continue by giving you the core of my
talk on speculative execution which as
you'll see is an old recipe with a twist
and we'll see what the twist is there in
the last few slides of my talk I'd like
to talk about an ongoing project
something that we just I did a few
months ago that addresses this issue of
building tools for distributed systems
that will help us you know fix some of
the problems that we have and this is
preliminary work but I think it's very
interesting and I thought it was worth
mentioning here I don't and I'll finally
conclude my talk so why do we need any
programming model
well reliability of the civil systems
and reliability in general of software
is a difficult problem so maybe we need
something that would help us specify
certain proper certain properties of of
the programs that we write that will
help us build better programs and there
are also historical reasons and this you
know graph here is not trying to be
comprehensive in any way it's just
showing some of the big players from the
C like family but what what really what
is showing us is that we need to come up
with models that are suited for the
ubiquitous computing environments that
we're working with these days and we
have seen in the past that the
environments have given the programming
languages and some cramming languages
like Java you know and the models that
they provided the programmers were there
because with the development of the web
and you know everything becoming
you know distribute in the sense where
you wanted to share pieces of code and
you weren't it will be able to run that
code safely on your system although
somebody else had written for you they
were providing this programming model
for that particular environments so mmm
no what are we doing now you know for
the new environments that we're working
on where we have you know every single
device that we have cell phones we have
even you know the DVDs everybody has all
these devices of a CPU in them that they
might be talking to each other how do we
handle this kind of the serious systems
but mainly I think we need a new
programming model because we need higher
level abstraction for the kind of the
civil system we're talking about these
days we would like to be able to say
something I want to achieve distributed
consensus between these nodes in the
system without really worrying about you
know how this is done other people have
done it for us and well it's to you know
not there's not a perfect solution for
for for all the requirements but for
most of the people that want this
functionality what we have there you
know could be good enough and also
programmers don't have to reinvent the
wheel every time they write this kind of
code also maybe we want some distributed
optimistic execution something where a
program optimistically executes and
involves other processes in its own
optimism optimistic execution but what's
really more important we really need to
make writing code easier and if we
manage to make writing code easier and
if we manage to make our codes simpler
then the programs that we write will be
shorter and we'll be able to reason
easier about that
I'm going to introduce the concept the
programming model that I worked on
through a very simple example this is in
fact the classical database example of
atomic money transfer you have two
accounts you want to transfer an amount
of money between these two accounts but
I presented here in a different a
slightly different context where what we
really want is we want to transfer two
blocks of data between two files and we
want to do this in an atomic manner so
if any of the operations that we have
held then we want to leave the system in
a consistent state so traditionally the
way you do this you create a temporary
buffers you heat those blocks of data
and you write them into the opposite
file well everything is fine if the
first three operations
you know either succeed or fail because
then the read operations don't really
change the state of the system whereas
the right if we assuming it to be atonic
then if it fails we know it hasn't
really changed the state of a system but
what happens if this right operation
succeeds and now the last operation
fails what you have to do in order to
leave the system in a consistent state
you'd have to undo the operations of the
first right which might or might not be
possible to do but even if it is
possible to do we have to write all this
recovery code in line with our
computation just to make sure you know
that things are left in a consistent
state
so what if we were to introduce new
programming model that would separate
this fault recovery code in this area
copied code from the actual computation
you know something that would tell us
that would provide for us fault recovery
for certain types of errors right
transparently something that would make
our code simpler what if we were just to
say well I'm going to speculate that all
these operations will be successful the
read and write operations now if any of
them fails I want the system to do all
the work for me we store the state to
what it was just before I entered this
speculation and maybe take a different
branch of execution just say you know I
tried this I want to return failure
we'll get there in just a second so
remember what I said initially it's an
old recipe but it has a twist to it so
this is the plain boring definition that
I usually give for transaction Asst
transaction define the speculation which
is based on an assumption whose
verification may be delayed but what do
I really mean by this a speculation the
way I define it is has three components
has the assumption which is a here on
which we base our computation then it
has the what we call the commit branch
which is the branch of execution that
gets executed assuming the assumption is
correct and then we have the abort
branch which is exactly that if the
assumption is invalidated now the idea
is that speculation is is equivalent to
either the commit or the abort branch
but not a combination of the two okay so
if we were to have an Oracle that could
tell us beforehand what the outcome of
the speculation is then the idea of
speculation could be written as the
following conditional statement if the
Oracle tells us the assumption is true
then executes the community ranch
otherwise executes the abort branch but
in practice we don't have this or we
don't know beforehand whether the
assumption is going to be true or false
so what we do is we start executing the
commit branch if everything goes well
and at some point we are able to
validate our assumption we commit the
speculation however if things go wrong
what we have to do we have to abort the
speculation go back the state and do the
effects of the commit branch and start
educating on the boatmen so as far as
we're concerned the commit branch is
sort of an atomic operation and if if
the assumption is invalidated then we
have to abort those if the effects of
those that of those operations we
introduced speculation through three
programming language construct
speculated returns the unidentifiable
speculation and then we have commit and
the board that are called whenever the
Assumption on which base our computation
is either validated or invalidated they
take the idea of a speculation and
commit doesn't do anything it just
avoid whereas the board doesn't really
have a return type because what it does
for you just rolls back the computation
and start executing the abort wrench so
it's like it never happened well as you
pointed out speculations share some
trades with database transactions but
when we're talking about distributed
systems and not only in the console
receiver system there is one major
difference you can imagine a speculation
being a transaction with no isolation
and while the typical transactions have
DAC property the atomicity consistency
isolation and durability we chose to
relax the isolation property why is this
important well I believe that in the for
the current environments that we write
software for relaxing the isolation
allows for increased parallelism we
don't have to close the world to the
program so all the actions are performed
inside the speculation are visible to
the outside world well of course the
impact of implementing such a grammy-maw
that has this loose isolation property
it makes implementation really hard
maybe but that's not the point this is
the kind of model that we want to have
right because it increases for Alice it
allows for all sort of interest
interesting concepts like the serious
optimistic execution and we'll see on
the next few slides how we can use
figurations you don't execute in
isolation
okay well Optima sitting away in this
case well you you can still define a
block as being atomic right as we've
seen on the previous example you say my
commit branch is an atomic operation if
if something goes wrong while I execute
the commit bank you know maybe my
assumption is the commitment is atomic
so you see in when we actually program
using speculations you don't have to
specify statically what the assumption
is the Assumption could be this block is
executed atomic and if anything goes
wrong something prevents me from
continuing my execution then I roll back
and maybe take a different execution and
consistency what this means is that
especially in the context of
distributive system it means that if I'm
a process and I send information to a
remote node as part of my speculation if
I aboard my speculation they will have
to do the throw back their state as well
to what it was they cannot have we
cannot have a computation of another
process in the system be based on an
assumption that has been observed
changes second cross section of the
second transaction of course right but
we don't have transactions here so well
it's different in in the following sense
that the way these propagate they're
subject to different constraints than
your traditional database transactions
so your database transactions typically
use or act on some shared database
content whereas here you have programs
you know you have individual states of
the programs and if a program size of
speculation commits the speculation it
starts another speculation commits the
speculation
as far as his concern these are this
happens sequentially because this is the
order of the execution on its local
execution thread and we do have signal
dependencies between the serial
speculations but the idea of sequential
consistency I don't think it applies
directly to to programming you can talk
I think both the sequential consistency
of some of the data over shared data or
something but not necessarily in the I'm
not sure if I understood your question
exactly you could so speculations is not
a solution that you know we just take
care of everything that's wrong with our
current computation as we will see it
some examples in a short while it can be
used to alleviate some of the problems
with the existing systems it could be
used to make writing certain kinds of
systems easier but it doesn't try to
wipe out the idea of locks it's not like
software transactional memory in that
respect if you want its we're trying to
provide programmers with some high level
primitives that for example they could
optimistically acquire a lock and
speculate
speculate that they will actually
receive the lock without having to wait
for that lock to be actually passed to
them so they speculatively execute you
gain some useful computation and we'll
see actually it's with some examples and
maybe that will answer your question yes
I understand the the transactions or
while the audio distributed in the
environment no such thing as distributed
transactions but this sauce to be the
problem that people dress in checkpoint
systems so we actually borrow some ideas
from you know the work done in in
checkpointing or all back and because
you know in order to maintain a
consistent descri estate for rollback
when you propagate speculative
information yes you actually have to
come up with the safe recovery line and
this is why I actually have here you
know this there's black things here are
actually checkpoints as as I labeled
them here and what you really need to be
able to do is you need to come up with a
lightweight mechanism for taking this
checkpoint so in this respect I think
we're different than traditional
checkpoint Angola we want to make this
usable on a on different scale when you
speculate we want to use speculations
more often in our programs and when you
speculate you don't necessarily have to
halt your program and hold maybe other
programs in in your distributed system
and say oh everybody let's just
checkpoint at this moment in time what
you want to be able to do is I want to
remember that when I bought my
speculation I have to roll back to this
point have a lightweight or an efficient
implementation of the scroll back
mechanism and combine this with
communication induced checkpoints so
when I send a message a speculative
message to other nodes upon their
receiving the speculative information
they'll have to remember where they have
to roll back if I abort my speculation
so we all we only have some message
passing for this particular model I'll
describe today and communication
generates what we call implicit
speculation if you receive a speculative
message you'll become part of this
implicit speculation
so on the next three slides I'll provide
three examples of programs that could be
implemented using speculations the first
one is a deserialization system I don't
expect you to necessarily you know look
at all the details of this of the solar
code for each of the entities I'm just
going to give you the big picture and
we'll investigate second execution paths
through two scenarios but what we do
have we have three entities a client the
flight agent and a hotel and this is
your typical reservation system the
client wants to atomically guarantee
that it can secure both a room at a
hotel and a flight given certain time
constraints and financial constraints
you know that has only sinned budget for
for this travel so the interaction that
we have between the entities is the
following the client speculates that it
will be able to get both the secure both
the hotel room and the flight so it
sends a request for quote both the hotel
and the flight agent on the hotel side
things are relatively simple the hotel
checks the local level ability it looks
in their books and say and they say yes
we do have a room for your particular
date and here's the price that we can
give you the room for as you observe
here upon receiving this speculative
request the hotel is actually acting
right now as part of this speculation
that the client initiated well the
flight engine things are a little bit
more complicated what it does is check
local reservation but the flight agent
doesn't have the ultimate answer to this
question the airline is the one that has
the exact number of people that are
registered because there are several
flight agents that can reserve flights
on a certain flight so it's speculated
that his local reservation actually is
consistent with the main information
held by the airline and it sends a quote
to the client this speculate this is a
nested speculation that flight agent has
and it's speculative information
will absorb the client in in that
speculation the client decides out yes
the prices are okay in the meanwhile the
flight engine received confirmation from
the airline yes indeed we do have spaces
let's comedic speculation and the
fighter income is the speculation this
also takes the notifies the client and
takes the client out of this nested
speculation finally the client acts in
its own way as described by the by the
program here sends a payment to both
entities and it secures its travel
finally commits the speculation this is
the good scenario
now what happens for example if the
airline says you know the flight is over
the other people there was somebody else
who took all the all the seats from this
flight well the flight engine has two
aboard it's speculation but this figure
figures and aboard both on the flight
agents side but also on the client side
so the client and the flight agent who
wrote back the flight agent at this
point will start executing it's a broad
range of the speculation and I'll say
you know I just received notification
the flight is full the client doesn't
even know that it initially received
that statement from the that message
from the flight engineer because each
state is rolled back to which was just
before receiving that message now I said
oh the flight is full I have to abort
I'm not able to secure this so what I'll
do I'll roll back my computation to my
initial state and try different agents
okay so another example that I have here
it touches on the optimistic speculative
execution in the case especially in the
case of a super system again there's a
lot of information here but I'll go
through it one step at a time
we're trying to implement an optimistic
tall order protocol under with using
speculation under setting assumptions
and the assumptions are here at the
bottom of the slide says we assume the
very reliable fiber channels between all
the entities in the system but and that
we also have a bounded Network laid
so if I send a message I know it will
get to the other node in a certain
period of time you know which is bounded
the other but we don't really know you
know how long it will take
in that particular window to get a
message in actually messages that are
sent given a universal global clock
could arrive in a different order at
their destination from from different
sources I mean also messages are labeled
with sequence numbers so message is
their actions in the system there are
strictly increasing but they're not
consecutive and they're also unique
right so you send a message you label it
somehow then five seconds later you send
another message even if nobody else in
the system sent the message during that
time your identifier doesn't necessarily
have to be consecutive to your previous
message right so this is an important
assumption classically the way you you'd
implemented hollow-core call given this
assumption is well you receive a message
and because you have Network latest
bonding that relate to see you can maybe
you can guarantee that in a certain time
especially if you have some pink
messages that are going on regularly
certain time you will either receive
confirmation that this is the right
message to send your application so you
can imagine as the pokel that I
described here is a layer that stands
between the network and the actual
application so you receive a message you
don't know if you can deliver this
message to the application right away
when you receive this message it could
be the case that you have to wait until
you a second period of time until you
receive confirmation that this is the
actual message that you have to do with
the application but in the classical
model what you do is you give a message
you wait for a tie a second period of
time and then deliver a message to the
application the application starts to do
some useful computation the optimistic
execution would say I receive a message
I know most of the time I'm correct by
just saying this is the next message
that I have to go to my application and
this is what we do here you start the
speculation and you say
this is the message that the application
should process if in this safe period in
this period of time we don't receive any
other message that invalidates your
assumption then what the application
does it does useful computation and then
when you give safe confirmation that
this was indeed the message that was
supposed to be delivered you commit the
speculation and you let the application
do some more useful computation so in
this case you actually gain some useful
computation by executing optimistically
what happens in the not-so-nice an area
when another message gets when you
receive another message with a lower
message ID well this is described in
this graph here you speculate you you
know the application does some
computation here that's not useful
computation you receive another message
that evaluates your assumption you have
to avoid a speculation but what you can
do now you can feed that new message to
the application say oh you know I think
this is an IA the right thing to do this
is the night and next message that you
have to process and you might do this a
few times but eventually you know you
will receive the next message to be
delivered to the application right and
you don't at that point you don't have
to wait for another period of time to
deliver the message you can
optimistically execute pass that on to
the application and you'll eventually
gain some useful computation options if
particular the sequence number
assumption this problem is very
analogous to help the problem he's
trying to solve by putting seamless
numbers by putting by seeing less
numbers in the messages why why is it an
interesting problem that you have a pair
of communicating things that can't use
consecutive sequence numbers where will
that happen well for example you could
imagine having having these entities
this nodes communicating with
with several groups and then you know
they increase their sequence number
every time they send a message in each
of the groups they're just a hard
problem that so if I understand your
problem you're trying to you're trying
to get sequential ordering on just one
pair you know you could have a coupe of
notes yes so it doesn't use not between
a pair of nodes you have seven several
nodes in your system and you want to
achieve tall order between all the
messages are sending in this all the
messages are being sent yes total order
is this this ID number at that yes and
you're responsible for coming up with
them yes and they can't come up with
this but the problem is that this is not
actually giving you consecutive numbers
but this is the behavior of one
particular node in the system and this
is why you actually you know when I said
reliable 5'4 channels when you have just
one channel between that yeah you won't
get me ordering between those messages
right because it's person first now but
the problem is when you have a node
between counting channels okay so this
is the actual context in which I
describe the problem for the serial
circulations you mean our agents knows
all right can get in situations when but
not sure well in the context of this
tall order protocol or in no because in
this I mean using because of using
because use speculations no in general
if the program is not reading correctly
I guess you could but I'm not sure how
this question will be addressed or is
related to this particular example this
is the last example that I'll use to
illustrate
you know speculations and how what can
we do with that this is a scientific
competing example where traditionally in
scientific computing you have a a
computation that you know gives you a
huge matrix maybe then you split this
among several compute air compute nodes
you know no 0 1 2 3 and the these nodes
have to run in lockstep and they have to
share some boarding information for each
step of their computation well what do
you do though if you want to have a
reliable program right we're in one of
your computation node fails you want to
be able to not necessarily start all the
way from the beginning but let's use a
mechanism that helps you roll back to a
more recent state you know
so traditionally the way you do this you
checkpoint your application at certain
time steps in their computation it's
like a synchronized checkpoint everybody
checkpoints on on step x but if you're
using pure checkpointing for this then
whenever a process fails not only you
have to move that process on a reserved
note that you have you know to restart
that computation but everybody else has
to blow their checkpoints from this
right and this puts a lot of pressure on
the actual storage system that you have
at your disposal right everybody all the
nodes in the computation have to read
this
you know heavyweight check point and
really start their stay
what if we were to use speculations for
this and what we say is between every
time you hit one of these
synchronization points you say I'm going
to speculate that everybody will make it
to the next synchronization point well
then you do this lightweight check
pointing and I'm going to give you a
hint here on how you do it we do it in
memory so you keep tracking memory of
this checkpoint and whenever computation
fails you only need to restart that
particular speculate that particular
note from this and the rest of the
computation is simply rolled back in
memory so you take some pressure off of
the actual storage system and by the way
these examples that are you know some of
the examples actually the last few
examples I talked about we did implement
them and you'll see a movie of how this
works actually in a speculative
environment and shortly and you can do
it in in a way that makes sense to the
application you don't have to just
blindly checkpoint the entire state of
the system you can even have incremental
checkpoints so but they're in memory so
there is a certain cost on that nothing
comes for free in the next two slides of
my talk I'll actually move on to a more
theoretical aspect of my work and try to
define a formal more speculations and
why do we need a formal as I mentioned I
initially think one of the problems with
writing distributed systems in general
is that people just jump into the
implementation so I don't really think
about well you know what does it mean to
rather the C program how does this
component affect other components in the
system so as part of my work I usually
like to focus on the formal math formal
side of things understand really the
problem for theoretical perspective and
once I have that I
can move on to the actual implementation
and the exciting benefits for it one of
it is that if you have a really clear
formal model clear specification then
you can make sure or this increases the
D confidence in your implementation
right if you're able to to write an
implementation that closely matches the
specification that you have then and if
you're able to prove the correctness of
your model then you're more confident in
your in your actual implementation but
there's another reason usually when you
introduce a new programming model and
you want people to use it if they want
to use it with their favorite model
checker tool or their favorite debugger
you could actually have to twist the
debugger or the model checker can't
extends these new concepts that you
introduced however if you have a formal
model for this new priming formal model
for the for this programming model and
then you can show that it's actually
equivalent to something that you can
already reason about then what you have
to do is as part of of this of making
the tools available just have some hooks
that transform your program into this
other model that you can reason about
and in this case actually I as part of
my research I showed that speculative
execution is really nothing more than
non-deterministic non speculative
execution where you know when you reach
a speculate point you either take the
suspect you the commit branch or the
abort branch depending on you know the
outcome of the speculation so if you're
able to have simple transformations like
this that take your speculative program
and show there is something you can
reason about you can make use of the
existing tools you know you can use your
favorite model checker or or rather -
there to reason about the correctness of
your program so
we do have the free syntactical concert
that i described before where
speculation has the commit branch the
abort branch you have commit and the
board and we also have two operations
that will help us with message passing
here we a process can send a message to
another process bi and a process
receives a message and uses it in its
computation described by e in this case
so this is a functional style
representation of days thanks so what we
need to do is we need to be able to
capture the state of this system and we
do this by capturing the state of all
the processes in the system somehow and
there are three main components to this
there is the program that the process
executes which is a sequence of
instructions you know you have a base
language and I assume there is a similar
operational semantics for whatever
language you have and you just extend it
with this contract then you have a set
of lightweight checkpoints that are
created for each of the speculations we
also have a received queue we only have
one received queue for all incoming
messages it doesn't matter who sends
those to you and this is just to
simplify the the model here there's also
an internal state of the process you
know like local variables and things
like that but this I didn't put this on
the slide here because it's not as
relevant and you know you just need to
know that it is there so who a
transformation goal that I have in my
equation sort of semantics shows the
transformation of the state of the
entire state system given at most one
process in the system executes one
instruction right so in this case I know
that in this transformation it was only
P I that executed you know instruction
II one in its program and I analyze how
this effects the rest of the system I'm
not going to give you all the details of
the rules I have probably about 25
something goals but I only talk about
some of the main players here
what happens when a process P I
speculate let's assume the cross is also
already part of two speculations so what
we need we need to do is we save a new
check point so that will tell us well if
you ever avoid the speculation you have
to go back to this particular state and
what we save in the state is the local
state of a process local variables and
so on but you also save the abort branch
what happens what does the what should
the program execute upon roll back and
as you can see it doesn't have to
execute the speculate block again it
only executes the abort branch and the
rest of the program okay so this is what
we actually save in this lightweight
check point what happens when a crosses
receives a speculative message this is
message M it's tagged with speculation
identifier as what it happens is this
the way the state of the system changes
is the following it's very seeming like
the speculate called because in this
case we have an implicit speculation the
main difference here we still save a
check point with the state of the
process and so on the main difference
here is that the abort and the commit
branch are the same because the
speculation is implicit the specular the
program itself in spec you didn't
specify an alternate execution path upon
rollback
it was implicitly absorbed in the
speculation so it only has to save the
same state here in this checkpoint the
same program to execute upon a wall back
what happens when you put a speculation
well if you aboard a speculation that
you own and assuming that this this
checkpoint here was saved as part of an
implicit speculation okay this is just
that one of the board will actually have
I think about eight or ten of them
handling different situation but what
does happen is you have to restore the
state you had for in that saving that
checkpoint so what you do is you take
the abort branch you start executing
that a part of Ti
but this is actually a two-fold process
when you bought a speculation that you
initiated first you have to roll back
your state but you
also have to let the other processes in
the system now that this figuration has
been aborted so at this point you don't
force them to rollback you just tell
them you know this speculation has been
aborted invalidate this checkpoint and I
have separate rules that say okay if you
have any validated checkpoint in your
system you don't really go on with your
execution you roll back to that
checkpoint and you extract whatever
state you save and execute that again so
you you roll back also if you're booked
a speculation and you have owned you own
some nested speculations there you have
to avoid those first and then eventually
abort the speculation so they will
receive a message and now you're in a
speculation that gets supported you do
you roll back to a point where you have
received the message or do you roll back
to a point for receiving the message yes
so you hold back to the point before
receiving the message so you and the
message is not in the queue because the
message gets invalidated as well as part
of the abort process this is what
happens when you you abort the stage and
I understand that they're their issues
with this model because you're putting a
lot of you're putting some some of the
work in the hands of the program right
now but you know what happens when if
you your program sends a message and
then on the abort branch doesn't send us
message again we can argue that that's
actually have a problem with their
program and this is the note the
expected thing to do in this case
because you're in a state where you're
waiting for a message and you got some
speculative information you process that
but that was not supposed to be there in
the first place so you go back to that
state waiting state and wait hopefully
for the initiative the speculation to
send you an on speculative message or
the correct thing
okay so just to summarize what we've
seen so far on speculations you know we
define a computation based on a certain
assumption whose verification we can
delay to a certain point in the future
and if you really think about
speculations in in the distribute
context what they are they extend the
exception mechanism right to this to be
environment you you have an exception
bigger than one node and that forces
other nodes that participate in this
computation to roll back their state
right it's very similar to the notion of
exceptions on sequential programs and
we're able to define safety cover lines
industry environments and provide
reliability for certain types of types
of applications also provide other
features like this will respect
optimistic distributed execution and we
actually did implement this I speculate
I send messages to remeasure guys and I
go into a long loop where I become
disconnected or due to a programmer I
don't send a commit or abort for a while
aren't they all loved hanging live long
well they do continue with their
computation as they would normally do
right this you they can commit their own
anything they can to all the other nodes
in the system well okay so there are
some limitations to this implementation
if you were for example to launch a
missile and you know as part of your
speculation Yuki obviously cannot take
that back right so as I said initially
this is not a solution that you know
fits all the programming needs that are
out there there certainly a message or
send something to but it actually
depends for example for debugging for
debugging purposes actually having as
part of a speculative computation having
printouts
does how who actually found out as we
were we're playing with this computer
model that you know in certain cases it
might be actually useful to have some
state that you cannot you know take back
you know just for debugging purposes and
other things but it is true when you do
some non an action that's not non
rolling back you cannot take it back
then yes you have to wait until that
happens and we easily which we put this
burden on the programmer to make sure
that when they when they do this when
they write speculative programs they
don't do it in weird ways however you
can imagine that there are certain
operations that you can actually up you
know do for example what if you were as
part of your speculative program ask you
know what the domain names are you know
what's the IP address of this domain you
know so idempotent operations can still
be performed the things that don't
affect the state of others is the other
process in the system in the outside
world right things like reading and and
so on they can still be so it doesn't
matter if you spite of your speculation
you query you know Mike what's the IP
address of Microsoft comm right if you
take back that speculation roll back the
name servers hasn't been affected
avoiding annoying transactions by notes
that we do so the way we implement this
if you are in a closed speculative
environment and everybody knows about
speculation and it just happens that one
of the nodes is disconnected the way I
implemented this and I'm I don't know if
it's the perfect way of doing things if
you're not able to communicate with the
initiator or speculate
in for certain period of time you assume
the speculation has failed and you hold
back your computation yes but these yes
do you have a reliable synchronous
network or but let's enter like Network
model here the way yeah well I do assume
some fault detection mechanism in the
network where I can tell well you can
never really tell this yes so in the
prototype that I have implemented myself
uses reliable UDP brood protocol
Holmwood protocol that to detect these
kinds of errors and you know I just
assumed that whenever timeout occurs is
actually the node that has failed so I
don't really treat network partitions no
is it so you just explain what's
important distinction it with partitions
and those places because both nodes are
running in heaven right just committee
consensus is impossible with
asynchronous unreliable networks and
this has it all up oh please I think you
know there's another point that you know
I didn't make in my in my flights here
is that the way things work is as far as
the initiator of a speculation is really
concerned it's concerned it doesn't
matter if some implicit speculative node
abort or not that doesn't affect
necessary it depends on the assumption
that you make but typically yes if an
implicit node fails does not mean that
the entire speculation has to be aborted
at least this is with more smalls that I
however if the initiator of the
speculation dies then yes everybody has
to abort that speculation right so
waiting free to Russians nice these
speculations what happens one house it's
a speculation yes we can't have those
and in trying to figure out I think for
our speculate is for you at munich i
right-click before a board especially a
lot of process aboard speculation
no you cannot it's only as i was trying
to make the point right now it's only
the owner of the speculation that can
abort the the outcome of that put your
expectations yes the initiate very diet
that means we recently say the
speculation has been aborted it's a
special case you know what you could go
the other way and say the speculation
has been committed but you have to
decide one way or another we chose the
more conservative approach so what if
the initiator believe is truck commits
says okay is it doesn't it does
speculation and then you know it says
okay and then it commits something but
after that commit then then it ceases
all communication and before it notifies
the other nodes of its commit in it does
so now everybody else is going to abort
even though something was committed
based on the assumption that that would
eventually commit sure but okay this you
can imagine this from the two points of
view right so from the point of view of
the initiator of the speculation the
rest of the world could be dead so the
initiator will still commit its own
speculation right and now you look at
the rest of the world they never seen
that commit message because the net the
the initiator has failed you know and we
also assume you know file stop you fail
you stop execution you don't come up
with a you know same ID necessarily and
try to
you know I didn't consider the case of
malicious computations and there is no
indicator I mean for a reliable message
it for a reliable message delivery you
require you require that a mess that a
node be always on so if I send a message
the only reason why that's reliable is
that I'm always going to be available to
respond to an actress but if I send a
message and then die yes then I can't
you if I ever I'm going to die in the
future I can't send reliable messages
right that's true and I believe that
this should not necessarily affect them
all that you have in you know it depends
on what define as consistency you know
for for this in this context but for
most applications that we have dealt
with this was not necessarily a this was
not a an issue so we we look at from the
perspective of each node and if the node
cannot contact you it just assumes
you're dead so it calls back the
computation which is the conservative
way of approaching this example that
means the airline sold you the ticket
and you go buy another one somewhere
else well you can assume that in certain
special cases you have the program
associate there is a slight different
here difference here between the
propagation of this messages and the the
other in the other communication that
the nodes are doing so if the nodes are
using let's say TCP mateesah P
communication right
you can piggyback some of the
speculative control messages on top of
that and you know provide the same
guarantees as TCP does its problem here
I mean you can't get out of this right
because it's a possibility for sure but
you know so no no what I'm saying is
that for soon
yeah we'll do face commitment comes the
light works by blocking you forever yes
right so yes you can have a protocol
that never completes or you can have a
protocol that's it
yeah sort of if you can't solve an
impossible problem well actually
oh yeah that's where we're trying to get
to okay so just to give you an idea here
so we did implement this as two options
well between different implementation
first we try to put speculative
execution part of a custom compiler and
everybody hated it because you know they
had to compile their programs using our
compiler was slow was a prototype
compiler so I decided to move more on
mainstream and provide this
functionality as part of a kernel I
provide support for local and the city's
speculation it's slightly more efficient
to the compiler because you you know I
did this as part of the Linux kernel
because it was available the source was
available and so I could play with it
and the nice thing about the kernel is
that also supports automatic
instrumentations of programs that don't
necessarily have an idea about
speculation so you can just trigger or
force a speculation on a program the way
we do with ballistic speculations
whether you're compiler you couldn't do
that because you had to use the compiler
to compile the code and this is the
example I showed before how speculations
and checkpoints work together and here's
what we have we have a competition it's
a heat propagation in a metal plate it's
a competition so when this node fails
we'll move it competition there all the
other nodes will all back to extol
whereas this one is restored from the
a heavyweight checkpoint that we saved
under again this node fails we recited
competition here all the surviving knows
simply roll back in memory the
computation and they go on with their
process
okay so in the next just you know ten
minutes or five minutes I'll talk about
this ongoing work this new pilot we
started and then I will conclude my top
I'm sure many of you have heard this
question have you fixed your box yet and
by the way this is not a typo it's
actually what we call our system and
even though we might come up with new
programming models that help write
better programs software barks will
still be there there might be conceptual
box that we have you know we did not
ascend really what the problem was or
how to implement it correctly and while
there are existing tools that may help
us identify or fix a green box you know
we have we can use log and we play you
know the typical example of this is you
have printouts and then you look at the
log and try to replay your program and
see what went wrong really we we also
have you know mal checker where you come
up with a model and model your an object
model of your program we run that and
then do an implementation and hope that
the to match but these tools don't
really scale very well to large system
then we have others you know we have
checked when I go back this can take
care of certain types of bugs where you
say there was a race condition and if I
check I go back my program to a
previously saved checkpoint maybe I can
pass that you know the resource won't be
shared between the same processes and
I'll I'll get by but think about the
extra work that you actually have to do
to get this running in a security
environment you cannot simply restart
one of your computations while the
others are still going on right you have
to roll back all of them token system
state to get a consistent computation
and you know this is a classical if you
want classical fixing mechanism where
you identify a bug in your program and
but your program is still running maybe
you know you
to some application you realize oh you
know the protocol that I have is not
quite correct maybe I need to to update
this so you know you have there the
other you know some academic projects
that are concerned with how you can
dynamically update your code code is
running you inject some things into it
and you know you make it run perfectly
but again where does this involve in the
context of this previous system can you
do it
by simply like that maybe not if you
just update one end of your
communication if you have two processes
that communicate with each other
and you update a protocol on just one
and then the other node will be lost so
what do you do there so few of these of
these tools work well for this to be a
parallel program so what we're trying to
do we're trying to make the distributed
component of this you know easier learn
why is it hard it's hard because of you
know several reasons traditional tools
they sometimes may be making use of you
of perfect information you have your
logs there you have your core dump maybe
on your local machine you put in the
debugger to analyze that for you and you
debug your code in a Desir environment
this might not be doable if a node you
know catches on fire somewhere else what
can you do about it and the other thing
is some of these tools that I mentioned
they're really interested in the exactly
in restoring exactly what happened to
your program right they want to trace
the execution patterns to tell you this
is what went wrong in this particular
run but would this really help you find
your box not necessarily what you really
want you're really concerned with what
went wrong with your computation what is
wrong with your program where other than
the exact instance in which it failed
right so by adapting some of these
requirements we might be able to come up
you know do something dinging do some
research we believe we can come up with
a better system something that will help
us you know help program works debug
receiver applications and this is how we
envision all these components of
system interacting with your computation
so you have a distribute computation
here and processes exchange messages
communicate with each other in various
ways we do hope to be able to gather
this global lock some a global log of
all the all these actions so that we can
still use a replay mechanism for certain
things and where this really comes
proves to be very useful is that if one
of the note dies and it's law just log
associated with it
it's unrecoverable maybe we'll be able
to figure out its execution based on the
other based on its interaction with the
other nodes in the system so if also if
we have a model of that know that failed
maybe we can play that along with the
log messages and figure out what really
happened what could go wrong now
traditionally you know you have your
execution and at some point your
processes fails ideally you'd like to
have what we call the time machine
mechanism true hole you go back the
entire state of the system the nodes at
least that you care about so this is the
other important thing to mention here
that if you use a mechanism like
speculative execution for example you
only go back the knows that you have
interacted with since your last
speculation or since your checkpoint you
don't have to really restore the state
of the entire system all the nodes in
the system all you knows that you care
about now once you're here in a
consistent state that maybe you can
reason it correctly segment variants are
still valid you can feed this to an
investigator and this is what I
mentioned before you know a model
checker but maybe it's a model checker
for actual programs rather than for
upstart models and why do we believe
doing this might work rather than just
using it in the first place because
you're not modeling your computation all
the way from the beginning you're just
feeding it midway through and say you
know I'm actually very close to this
crash that happened so I know this is a
consistent state can you explore all the
possible execution or at least to
certain depths and give me back feedback
what went wrong now once you have that
feedback
you know you don't really have one to
necessarily investigate all possible
execution I'd infinite them you just
want to say this is what I have for
running you know 100 levels down I fill
this to the healer and the healing is is
not it's the combination of user and
dynamic updating tool or whatever other
tool you know we could we can find there
that will help you once you figure out
what the problem is help you inject
correct code in that state there and let
you let you bypass this error and
continue execution now without actually
having to crash your programs so in
conclusion I'd like to say just a few
words know I believe that the ability is
really more difficult to achieve in the
context of established systems and you
know just to paraphrase Leslie Lamport
the problem here is that a program you
really you know never heard of could
prevent you from doing useful work you
know something that you never know even
knew it existed could prevent you from
hungry useful work and we need to
overcome some of these problems you know
try to come up with new programming
models that would alleviate some of the
problems some of the issues related to
software reliability in the context of
these environments and my solution to
this is you know come up with this idea
of speculations which is transaction
with no isolation and I believe it does
a good job of addressing some of these
issues it's not a perfect solution but
it's step forward and you know it could
certainly be improved forever so thank
you very much for your attention
this time easier so going back to the
Leslie statement about some program that
I've never heard of caused me not to
make progress it seems like you've done
absolutely nothing for that what I mean
by that is some program that I've never
heard of that just communicated with
somebody that I've communicated they're
gonna board and that means everything
that isn't that causal future I now have
to roll back guess what I'm really
trying to water any key that is what do
you think it may be is here what I made
easier is I made for one I said so there
were three things one in a few
speculations for certain types of
applications you can replace the error
recovery code so you don't really have
to worry about if your computation abort
let's say you're gonna do a computation
you don't have to worry about sending
messages to you know other nodes in the
system saying oh you know the
computation that I have here is wrong so
I'm hiding some of the communication
details what this makes for you this is
one of the main advantages
it makes your program simpler right so
you just say speculate perform these
operations abort or commit based on the
assumption that you have when you have
simpler programs you can reason easier
about their correctness you don't have
assuming that the rest of the components
are doing the right thing and you know
what their specifications are then you
can say I know these components are
correct I'm going to make use of them
and this is what my code does is it
correct does it perform to the
sophistication that I want so this is
one of the main advantages the other is
that you have in the context of
distributed systems you can have you can
reduce or you can optimize the
computation by having optimistic exit
disputed optimistic execution where you
you know the fact that certain nodes
pass a synchronization point
optimistically doesn't have to
mean that you know they have to write
ugly code to restore their state or that
they have invalidated an invariant in
the system yes and yes you can say that
you know maybe I haven't done much on
you know this remote system preventing
you from from doing work but if all
programs were actually you know Weedon
with higher level in you know high level
abstractions then maybe we could be able
to reason about their characters better
and maybe you know this would alleviate
some of the you know the software
problem of software reliability so it
might make keep other people they ride
this remo softer ride better software
which could fix the issue